so I want to chat about something very
interesting about the corona virus
typically the symptoms and there's
actually quite a lot of different
symptoms but mainly you get fever you're
tired a dry cough shortness of breath
sore throat
your lungs start to become inflamed and
there's a series of symptoms but
recently there's been an observation
that there's an additional symptom okay
and it's a loss of smell the medical
name for loss of smell is and Nos me up
OK you can also get a loss of taste
where everything just tastes like
cardboard that has been recently found
to be a common symptom of the corona
virus so the question is why and I have
some ideas the first thing I want to
tell you is that there's a certain
enzyme that's involved in your
perception of smell and taste and this
is the name of the enzyme carbonic
anhydrase 6 and this essential enzyme
for taste and smell is zinc dependent ok
and now I'm not sure that you know this
but one big symptom of a zinc deficiency
is a loss of smell and a loss of taste
you can even go online and order a zinc
test which basically you take a little
zinc and you put it in your mouth and if
you cannot taste anything your zinc
deficient because usually zinc tastes
very metallic so if you actually taste
that metallic taste you have enough zinc
if you don't taste it you are deficient
so you can actually get that test and
see for yourself but if you do research
on this symptom alone ok a loss to smell
it will list a series of causes and I'm
going to go through them and I want to
show you how many of them are related
and connected to zinc because I really
think the reason for this symptom is a
zinc deficiency for a couple reasons one
is that when you go through an infection
especially in your lungs you use up a
lot of zinc zinc is not stored that
well so unless you're constantly
consuming zinc chances are you're going
to be deficient on top of that if you
get this infection you're gonna be even
more deficient and zinc has a huge
purpose of protecting you against
microbes and especially viruses it's a
really key immune protector for the
immune system so let's take a look at
the causes of loss of smell first of all
we have upper respiratory infection we
already know that 16 percent of
pneumonia cases are actually caused by a
zinc deficiency okay so there's
definitely that relationship nasal
polyps next one idiopathic hypo
gonadotropic hypogonadism now say that
three times real fast
basically the testicles are shrinking
and idiopathic means we don't know why
okay unknown cause well guess what zinc
deficiency will cause hypogonadism as
well as low testosterone next one
hypothyroidism antibiotics diabetes high
levels of sugar in the blood will
deplete zinc fYI Cushing syndrome this
is a condition where you have high
cortisol high cortisol and or stress
will deplete zinc and then we have the
next one cadmium poisoning cadmium
cadmium is a toxic heavy metal that will
definitely deplete zinc so that's
probably why you have a loss of smell
because the cadmium depletes zinc and
then you have this next one which I
already told you a zinc deficiency so
loss of smell could be caused by a zinc
deficiency
here's next one coal man syndrome what
is this this is a genetic condition
where you have hypogonadism then we have
this last one primary ciliary dyskinesia
now what the heck is that and this just
means the genetic disorder involving a
function of your sperm well guess what
sperm is highly influenced by the amount
of zinc in your body so what can we
learn from this information well the
loss of smell potentially could be a
zinc deficiency and if you take zinc not
only will you be able to improve the
sense of smell but you will also
increase the strength of the immune
system so what can someone take away
from this information well just the
importance of zinc and how vitally
important it is not just for smell but
to protect your immune system to
decrease the duration where someone is
going through an infection and the fact
that when someone has an infection
they're probably already deficient so if
you haven't seen my video on boosting
the immune system check it out I put it
right here